the two triangles shown below are
similar
identify their corresponding sides and
angles so we see here based on how it's
marked that this angle is equal to that
angle this angle with two arcs here is
equal to this angle with two arcs here
and this angle over here with three arcs
is equal to this angle with three arcs
over there so that's how we can identify
which angles correspond to which other
ones so for example
angle
angle c a b
angle c
a b
corresponds corresponds to this angle
over here which we can call
which we can call f d e
corresponds to angle f
d
e
if we say angle abc
angle a
b c
this corresponds so now we're looking at
this angle right over here angle abc
corresponds to angle
d
e f
angle d
e f and then finally angle
bca
angle b
c a which is that angle over there
corresponds we look at the three bars
corresponds to angle e f d
corresponds to angle e
f d now when we think about
corresponding size and let me color code
it actually that'll make it a little bit
more interesting
side a b
so let's say
side a b
side a b
segment a b i guess you could call it
corresponds to what well you can tell by
looking at the angles this is the side
between this one arc angle and this two
arc angle the side between the one arc
angle and the two arc angle it
corresponds to side d e on this triangle
the segment to segment de
then if we look at at bc right over here
if we look at bc right over here
bc
corresponds to it's between the two bars
and the three bars between the two bars
and the three bars it corresponds to ef
ef
another way that you could think about
it is that this blue side is opposite
this angle
angle
edf so it's or fde we called it well we
called it fde over here it's opposite an
angle and it's opposite this angle the
one arc angle the one arc angle this
orange side was opposite the three arc
angle it was opposite the three arc
angle and then finally
if we look at
this side right over here ac
ac
it corresponds to well it's the only one
that's left but it's also ac is opposite
that two bar angle opposite that two-bar
angle is right over here it corresponds
to side
df this corresponds to side df on this
smaller triangle right over here and
we're done we've shown all the
corresponding sides and angles